[Music]
[Applause]
Ian Rapaport NFL Network nfl.com Insider
and you can see him Monday through
Friday on the Insiders at 1 Eastern also
Dolphins Chiefs airs Sunday at 9:30 a.m.
eastern exclusively on NFL Network Ian
thanks for joining us what's the deal
that didn't get done
yesterday hi sorry about that
um the deal that didn't get done
yesterday anything close that didn't get
done or you thought that there was talk
about um I would
say there's not a lot that got close
that didn't get done because usually
what happens is if a team is talking
about it when you get to like Monday or
Tuesday usually those teams want to do a
deal right um I was a little surprised
Hunter Renfro didn't go to the Saints I
thought there was a chance that might
happen now once the Monday deadline at
4M came up of players contracts to be
adjusted pre-trade once that happened
then a deal wasn't going to happen but I
think that was one that I thought um you
know I was maybe a little surprised that
Denver or Minnesota didn't trade off any
of their big pieces but Denver won and
kind of has like sneakily looked not bad
the last couple weeks and then the
Vikings are at 500 so I understand why
those deals didn't get done um but I
mean you know it was another deadline of
us talking about some really big names
and then sometimes some other big names
were the ones that ended up getting
dealt uh help me understand what Mark
Davis and why he decided to make this
move with his coaching staff yeah I mean
the coaching staff I can sort of
understand Josh McDaniels fired last
night around
9:45 uh actually I think 10:45 Eastern
around 7:45 local time then the news
announced by the team 1:00 a.m. eastern
time you know the product was really bad
I mean for a team that's like kind of
talented the product on the field was
really bad Jimmy Garoppolo played bad
the offense has been bad I'm using the
word bad a lot because it's bad um and I
think that for the coaching staff makes
sense so what went into Mark Davis's
decision is he's been having meetings
over the course of the last week or so
dinners meetings Etc with some of the
key team leaders Damonte Adams Josh
Jacobs
um Etc and kind of getting an
understanding of like the culture the
locker room helping him inform his
decision then ended up you know leading
Josh mcdo to get fired I was a little
more surprised that the general manager
Dave Ziggler got fired that to me was a
little surprising because usually GMS at
least get to pick their aad coach these
guys kind of came in together but you
know this was the decision that was made
and that's you know what Mark Davis went
with which is a clean house and starting
over but did that impede them maybe
making any moves uh that the fact that
you don't have a coach or a
GM no now this all happened the actual
news happened after the deadline
yesterday right but obviously for Mark
Davis he knew that something may be
going on I would say for about a week or
so those in the building were like this
is bad or something is not right okay so
like you knew something was happening
but it seemed to me that the reason they
didn't trade I guess Devonte Adams would
have been the big piece although people
called about Josh Jacobs they called
about Max Crosby the reason why is that
Mark Davis likes the players and
basically his choice was I want to keep
these players and win with these players
we just need a better Coach and I guess
general manager to do it that was kind
of the decision that he went through and
that's why it wasn't a fire sale how
attractive is this
job it's a head coaching job in the NFL
um they're not a lot of those um it is a
roster that has some Talent has some
young talent definitely need a
quarterback a well I shouldn't say
definitely may need a quarterback adid
no Connell is the rookie fourth rounder
he's going to start this week There's
he's pretty impressive and there's some
people that really really really like
him if he's the guy if they find Kirk
Cousins whoever then this is more
attractive right um but I would say you
know it's attractive and that there's
pieces I think what you're asking is
does Mark Davis make it more
unattractive right is that fair yeah and
I would say every owner wants to win
very badly like I UND I think Mark Davis
wanted to show more patience but given
with the product they showed on national
TV I understand why he did what he did
with the coaching staff like I don't
think this is like a rash non-thinking
decision made by Mark Davis I think it
was a wellth thought out decision what's
Brady's involvement with the
Raiders um if he has any involvement and
I have not heard that he does then it is
essentially as an informal right because
he's not an owner he doesn't have a deal
there he's not able to sort of function
on behalf of the team in any like that
his ownership stake has not been
approved then it is not official and
it's not happening um I I never was told
by anyone I would trust that Mark Davis
is leaning on him I would be curious
what he would have said for one of his
favorite coaches being fired but I never
knew that Brady was consulted on this
and I never heard that his deal is done
anyway help me understand what's going
on in
Washington that one is a little sort of
easier to to grasp I think for for Josh
Harris and the new owner um I think what
he has wanted was the ability to have
some resources right now obviously the
commanders had two guys they could have
paid they had Chase young they had
Montes sweat in the end they decided
that instead of paying both which was
never really G to happen one was
probably going to leave in free agency
get what amounts to a compensatory pick
now okay for Chase young that makes
sense and then the Montes sweat deal was
just too good to pass up because if
you're the commanders it's not just do I
want to keep Montes sweat it's do I want
to keep them plus $25 million or
whatever it ends up being so I have no
idea whether or not Washington is going
to need a quarterback for the future but
I know it's possible and so basically
what they did was say we are going to
say goodbye to two edges who we really
like but he were going to be very
expensive and we're going to get more
picks in case we need to use them to go
find a quarterback and the fact that we
have to start over from the ground up is
okay and obviously calls into question
like are there going to be some other
people who are going to be starting over
coaching staff personel like there's a
lot of questions and I think all those
were already there but it just kind of
heightens those questions Ian Rapa Port
NFL Network Insider what are the Bears
doing
so of all the things this was the one
the Montes sweat deal was the one that I
think was the biggest
curiosity I my personal opinion which
matters literally zero um with all due
respect to myself um I kind of liked it
because what it was was you put a little
deposit in a second round pick and you
get a great free agent for the future
who will now you will now pay right um
we've seen people do it in the past Dave
Gman did it for Leonard Williams
everybody lost their mind turned out to
be a great deal he was a pro bowler for
the Giants that's what the Bears are
hoping for you pay a little bit now you
get Montes SED who might not have signed
there in free agency no would not have
signed there in free agency and you pay
him and you just add to a really good
roster it is not for everyone some
people would rather just take your
chance in free agency and have the
second rounder but you know what you are
getting you know that Montes SWAT is a
good player that's why to me that pick
seems worth it if the ners didn't lose
three in a row would they have traded
for Chase
young uh the way they lost it I would
say that definitely contributed you know
what I mean like the defense really
struggling not having the front end
together with the back end and kind of
giving up a bunch of point now Joe
burough is awesome so like awesome but
some of the other losses not as much
definitely contributed and I think for
the 49ers like this is what the trade
deadline is for
right you have a team that's really good
who struggled a little bit who's like
you know what instead of being all good
we need one we need a little infusion of
juice remember a couple years ago the
49ers traded for Emanuel Sanders and he
kind of like gave them that juice for
the second half of the Season like I
could kind of see Chase young being that
like it's not like okay well now they
have an edge presence opposite Nick Bosa
they're good it's not like that it's
just sometimes new energy and new Talent
helps everyone I think that's what
they're hoping for what's Arizona
doing uh they're waiting for Kyler um so
the Josh dobs deal made sense because he
was probably going to be the backup so
you get a little pick for him lets him
go start totally fine um I think they
want a look at their Young quarterback
which they're going to get uh Clayton T
and that's cool and they're going to see
him this week and then Kyle either plays
a little bit this week possible or
doesn't and just waits till next week
and at least Arizona gets a look at do
we have a backup quarterback for the
future or not um the other thing is
Kyler's been practicing for it'll be
three weeks and then it'll be four weeks
before his start so that's training camp
I think the most important thing for
them is is Kyler at 100% when he plays
and I think that's where he's going to
be next week assuming he starts good to
talk to you as always know you're busy
thanks for uh spending some time
absolutely man take care that's Ian
raport NFL Network nfl.com National
Insider and you can see the Chiefs and
the Dolphins keep this in mind write it
down because that's 9:30 a.m. eastern on
Sunday from Frankfurt Germany